I wanted to know you're all about
inspiration and everything I've been
feeling a little bit unmotivated and
I've been feeling like I should be doing
something or I should be just I feel
like I should be pulled in like it is an
unfeeling uninspired face okay that's my
question how do you get when you lose
inspiration or you lose motivation how
do you get it back I get it back by
remembering that you might die tomorrow
that's true
so I'm inspired by practicality and
reality and the truth which is it is
ridiculously impossible to become a
human being I am one I have other good
things going for me as a human being and
I'm just grateful you your dwelling and
looking at what you don't have versus
looking at what you have if you actually
looked at what you had your health you
know living in America you know who the
heck knows what would be on your list if
you actually spend all your time looking
at that versus I don't have a million
dollars I'm not famous I don't have this
if you spent all your time on what you
have versus what you don't have you will
be the happiest girl on earth
[Music]